if there's one skincare
ingredient that works it's retinol
pretty much everyone agrees - whatever skin
concern you have it's one of your best bets
but is it all a scam?
quite a few dermatologists and
scientists don't think retinol works
"there is very little if any trustworthy
evidence available to support the use
of retinol containing products to
improve the appearance of aged skin"
"I think they are a total waste of time and money"
and I can see where they're coming from
when I started looking at skincare during my
medicinal chemistry PhD I saw a huge difference
between what scientists are taught is good
evidence and what I was seeing for skincare
but after 12 years of studying skincare science
learning about the cosmetic industry and getting
qualified as a cosmetic chemist I feel
like I can finally explain to you why
skincare science looks so un-sciencey
and how to find products that work
now some of you are probably thinking she's just
defending this scam because she's
been sponsored by skincare companies
but a lot of non-sponsored scientists and
dermatologists agree and once I break it
down I think a lot of things that you've
noticed about skincare will suddenly make
a lot more sense and you'll find it easier
to pick out evidence-based skincare products
retinol is a retinoid these are ingredients based
on vitamin A and they're
the superstars of skincare
they work for lots of things
like acne pigment and wrinkles
but not all of them have
the same level of evidence
some of these are drugs they
have been extensively studied
and that's where a lot of that great
reputation for retinoids comes from
but what about retinol?
PubMed is a database where most
peer-reviewed clinical trials are listed
this is where products have actually
been tested on someone's skin and then
other scientists have looked over
the study before it got published
if we do a really basic search for retinol
clinical trials it's not really looking great
we've got 39 results and a lot of these
aren't actually on retinol on skin
this is a pretty typical retinol study that you'll
see and it's actually one of the better ones
we've got 40 subjects which is
pretty low by medical standards
but actually really good by skincare standards
it's placebo controlled which
means the skincare product was
compared with a cream that didn't have any actives
it's double blind which means both the volunteers
and the people taking the measurements of
the skin didn't know which product was
which so they are hopefully less biased
but you can see here we've got retinol it's
also combined with lactose and glycolic acid
so you don't actually know if it's the retinol
working or if it's one of the other ingredients
most of the authors are also from
Johnson and Johnson which is the
company that makes the product so there
is a potential conflict of interest there
and we haven't even opened
the paper yet so I'm sure
once we get in there there'll be even more issues
so why does the evidence for the best
skincare ingredient look like this?
well a lot of this is the government's fault
thanks obama
most countries draw a line
between drugs and cosmetics
drugs are defined as products that can treat
disease or they can change the
structure or function of skin
before an ingredient can become a drug
it has to go through an approval process
this involves doing a whole bunch of
studies including on lots and lots
of people to show that it is actually effective
the company then takes all this data
and submits it to a regulatory agency
they make sure there's enough evidence to
say that it works and it becomes a drug
on the other hand cosmetics are
defined as products that have
superficial effects they just
change the appearance of skin
retinol is classified as a cosmetic so this
kind of makes it seem like retinol doesn't work
it feels a lot like this
do you know what they call alternative
medicine that's been proved to work?
medicine
what this is missing and this is crucial
a lot of the time whether something
becomes a drug is less about what it
does and doesn't do and more about other reasons
this drug versus cosmetic definition was
created almost a 100 years ago before we
as a species realized bloody everything can
change the structure and function of skin
at least in little ways including water
and even just a piece of plastic tape
I mean look at these effects it
is pretty intense for something
that literally just sits on top of
your skin and doesn't even go in
and some ingredients are drugs in one
country and cosmetics in other countries
it's not like you can tell a molecule what it can
and can't legally do to your skin
after you've crossed the border
you just can't
they won't hear you
they don't have ears
so this is a common misconception
how cosmetics are legally defined doesn't match
what cosmetics are actually doing to your skin
but at the same time it would
be ridiculous and unnecessary
to regulate water and sticky tape as drugs
the way it mostly works in practice
is that cosmetics aren't meant to
claim that they can change the
structure or function of skin
and if cosmetic companies start selling really
potent and potentially dangerous
stuff then the government steps in
but with retinoids you might be wondering
they all kind of do the same
thing they work in the same way
but some of them made it to the drug side
why is retinol over here?
this is a really good question and it's
almost entirely a historical accident
here's a dermatologist who was involved in
the original research on retinoids for skin
how did it come about that retinol is over
the counter and retinoids are prescription
the reason is retinol has been in in
a lot of products including cosmetics
for a long time for its antioxidant properties
so it was already in over the counter products
and then as as it became apparent and the work
of Sewon Kang and John Voorhees where they
showed retinol was a prodrug of retinoic acid
once we became aware of all that then obviously
retinol might have some some benefit and it
it clearly does there are many many good really
good studies that show that's definitely benefit
so the FDA couldn't say well we can't
allow this over the counter because
it's already there you know for another
reason just in a different concentration
so there are some good reasons why
retinol isn't legally classified as a drug
but if it works then where
are the scientific studies?
here's the thing with the
peer-reviewed scientific literature
not everything has an equal
chance of ending up in here
there are a lot of good reasons
why we don't see high quality peer
reviewed clinical trials on cosmetics that often
yes one of these reasons is that a lot
of stuff probably doesn't work that well
but a really important reason
that gets missed a lot is
there is just not that much incentive to do them
research costs a lot especially clinical trials
most peer-reviewed research is funded by taxes
it's a lot easier to get funding
to research heart disease than skin
and within skin research it's a lot
easier to get money to study drugs
approved to treat medical conditions
than How Retinol Make Skin Look Nice
that means more skin studies are funded
by ingredient and skincare companies
which isn't as nice because there
are potential conflicts of interest
but even if the studies were 10,000% honest that
still changes the sorts of studies that get funded
as someone who owns skin I would love more
high quality clinical trials on skincare
it's nice simple direct evidence
you literally put the thing on a
bunch of faces and see what happens
but that's not how companies think
they don't have skin
back to the government
companies are going to do less trials on cosmetics
clinical trials are actually needed before
you sell a drug but cosmetics don't need them
if a company doesn't need to pay
for an expensive thing they are
probably not going to pay for that expensive thing
and it is expensive back when I had
less back pain a proper clinical
trial for a dermatology drug cost $1.5
million (not adjusted for inflation)
that drug versus cosmetic definition means
that even if a cosmetic "did something"
in a clinical trial the company
can't just slap that on a billboard
so it isn't exactly the most guaranteed return on
investment compared to everything else
a company could spend their money on
let's say a company has decided
to pay for a clinical trial and
they often do despite all of these barriers
well-designed experiments are a great way
to test what works and make better products
yay scientific method
but publishing a study in a peer-
reviewed journal is a choice
the company could also just NOT publish it
and just use the findings to improve their
own products instead of giving
free info to their competitors
and this happens a LOT
I've consulted for some companies who
invest a lot in R&D and it is extremely
obvious that what we actually see is a tiny
sliver of the actual research they've done
now for academic scientists doing
good research and not publishing
it in a peer-reviewed journal is super weird
I know because academia is where I was made
and it's because the incentives
are so different there
part of why academics publish papers is
because it contributes to scientific knowledge
it's just "how science is done" and that idea
contributes to a lot of Industry publishing too
but a very big part of it for academics
is that's how you keep your job
it's "publish or perish" - your peer-reviewed
publications are really important when
universities decide who to hire and who to
promote and when research funding gets decided
so the peer-reviewed studies that do
come out are going to lean towards
maximum benefit to the company at a minimal cost
and a lot of the time this is just
the opposite of good study design
for example a well-designed trial to test retinol
would mean it's tested on its
own against a vehicle control
that means you're testing a cream
with retinol against the exact same
cream without retinol to make
sure it is that retinol working
if you're Big Cosmetic Company you've just
paid a whole bunch of money to show that
retinol and ingredient that every other
company can use in their products works
on the other hand you can spend the same amount
of money and test your specific retinol formula
against a plain cream or even against nothing just
to rig it a bit and make your product look better
so if you're looking at it as purely an
investment it kind of leans very much one way
"well designed" also usually means
more participants repetition is
really important in science the
more times you test something the
more confident you can be that your
result isn't just a one-off fluke
in drug trials they test on
hundreds or thousands of people
most cosmetic trials have less than 30 people
why would you pay for 300 people when you could
just pay for 30 and still be
doing more than everyone else?
so there are a lot of reasons
why a cosmetic company probably
isn't going to pay big bucks for
a well-designed clinical trial on
retinol that they'll publish in a peer
review journal that ends up on PubMed
the only real incentive would be to get
new customers who are nerdy enough to be
impressed by a well-designed clinical trial
but they don't already think retinol works
this is a really really tiny group of
people again just an awful investment
especially since pretty much everyone
who understands retinoid pharmacology
accepts that at least some retinol products work
so why?
why do so many scientists think retinol works even
though we don't have that many
high quality clinical trials?
even kligman (boo hiss) who
invented tretinoin and has a
reputation for maybe hyping
it up a little bit too much
even he says retinol which is
a competing ingredient works
I love clinical trials I think all scientists do
thing go on face face change nice
nice
but I think sometimes we forget that
the whole point of of science is to
build an understanding of the world so
we don't have to directly test everything
clinical trials have been
important for such a long
time because human biology is really complicated
clinical trials aren't really used for better
understood areas of science like astrophysics
it can be hard to accurately predict
what happens when you take a pill
the ingredients have to travel through your
digestive system get absorbed go into your
blood get processed by your liver and then end
up in the right part of your body before it works
but skin products are less complex
they just have to go through a relatively
short distance through your skin so it
is a lot easier to work out what's
going on from other types of evidence
and our scientific understanding
of human biology is also improving
for example in toxicology
there's been a lot more use
of new approach methods instead of just
directly testing on animals or people
and this sort of scientific reasoning and
extrapolation is used in clinical trials too
if a drug works in a clinical trial in one
place we assume that it's going to work in
lots of other people in lots of other
places maybe years after the original
and that's because thanks to science we know
that human biology doesn't evolve that quickly
drug molecules aren't really
affected by where you are
clinical trials for tretinoin didn't tell people
whether they should be sitting or standing while
applying it because again thanks to science we
know that's not going to change how it works
so there's actually a lot of other
scientific evidence on retinol and
when you put it all together it builds
a really convincing case that if we had
the incentive to do high quality clinical
trials they would find that retinol works
one of the key pieces of evidence
is that in your skin retinol can be
converted to tretinoin which is an approved drug
there's a lot of evidence that tretinoin works and
we also know a lot about how it works
its pharmacological mechanism of action
so far this isn't a slam dunk we still
need that tretinoin that gets formed
from the retinol to end up in the right
place and at a high enough concentration
luckily we do have evidence for this
we also have evidence that applying normal amounts
of retinol to skin will change the
level of substances inside the skin
these are the same ones that change
with tretinoin and they're expected
to be an important part of
how tretinoin actually works
and for each of these we have
multiple types of evidence
we have studies on mice on people on bits of skin
removed from people on different
types of isolated human skin cells
you might have also experienced
some evidence for yourself
if you've ever used a little bit too much retinol
you might have noticed a special kind of peeling
it's not the same as the kind of peeling
you get from other irritating products
there is a delay and it feels like you
just have a little bit too much skin
this is a pretty unique side effect
of retinoids it has a special name
retinization or retinoid dermatitis and
it happens because of how retinoids work
activating retinoic acid receptors
triggers the epidermal growth factor
pathway and this leads to more cells being
produced in the top layers of your skin
there's also those not as high quality
clinical trials that we do have
despite all of this lack of incentive
making the bar way higher for conducting
and publishing them retinol still
has a lot that show promising results
and this evidence includes studies
from independent research groups
that don't have funding from cosmetic companies
a lot of the studies that were funded by cosmetic
companies were done in conjunction
with independent academic researchers
and the industry funding for these studies
comes from lots of different cosmetic companies
there are also studies on other cosmetic retinoids
with results that wouldn't really
make sense unless retinol worked
it's just really really unlikely
that all of these scientists and
companies are part of some huge conspiracy
that's been going on for almost 30 years
so in this situation where there are very good
practical reasons why high quality peer-reviewed
clinical trials aren't there and there is
an overwhelming amount of other scientific
evidence that something works I think it's really
reasonable to conclude that retinol probably works
now I'm not saying that you can't
choose to only use ingredients that
have well-designed clinical trials that
is a completely reasonable personal choice
but saying that the only ingredients that work are
the ones with high quality clinical trials
and anything without that specific type
and level of evidence is completely
useless that is actually unscientific
and there are some upsides that
cosmetic retinoids have that drug
retinoids don't and I'll be talking
about those in a different video
I've mostly talked about retinol which is
the skincare ingredient with
the most evidence behind it
but there are a lot of other things
that we can take from this journey
that can help us find other effective ingredients
this is the lab muffin matrix it
shows how to think about the evidence
when you're deciding if a skincare
product has a good chance of working
the left hand side is about ingredients
you want to see if the active ingredient
can theoretically work this is
looking at things like chemical
properties mechanism of action
cell studies and animal studies
do we know how it works? what it's interacting
with inside the skin? can it get into skin?
you also want to see if the active ingredient
has been actually tested on people's skin
we're looking for clinical
studies and biopsy evidence
now the right hand side is about specific
product formulas again you want to see if it
can theoretically work and if that formula
has actually been tested on actual people
some ingredients are easier to formulate with
so you don't have to do quite as much guess work
but others are more annoying like if
they're unstable which is the case
for a lot of retinoids I'll be talking more
about this but a good general guideline is
to look for products from companies
who invest in product development
and for all of these if there are more different
types of evidence more different scientists
contributing to this body of evidence more
repetition of findings you can be
more confident about the conclusion
once you have a retinoid product you'll need to
know how to apply it so I take
you through that in this video
the next best skincare active is probably vitamin
C and I have a guide to choosing those too